слуга народу збираєтеся ще наповнити цей
важливий суд саме партійними кандидатами
що унеможливить апріорі е незалежність
Конституційного Суду ми Закликаємо колег
від слуги народу утриматися від
формування конституційного суду за
партійним принципом очевидно що судді
Конституційного Суду мають бути А
професійними б позапартійними в-
незалежними і це відповідає вимогам
Європейського Союзу Ну і в принципі
демократичним правилам І ну ви вже
делегували з порушеннями До речі закону
пані совгирю до Конституційного Суду і
зараз ще двоє депутатів від слуги народу
Як ми знаємо претендують на посади
суддів конституційного суду